this is the Canadian framework
pronounced Ken Levin for those of you
who don't speak Welsh now the origin of
the name itself is deserving of
explanation its literal translation is
habitat or place but what it actually
means is the place of your multiple
belongings it's this very sense that
you're rooted in many different paths
which profoundly influence what you are
but of which you can only ever be
partially aware and the reason it's a
good name for a complexity model is
that's a complex system yeah thousands
of module 8 is influencing the
development of the system they influence
what you are but you can never fully
know what they are a couple of key
points to make about the model first of
all it's a sense making model not a
categorization model and the difference
there is key a categorization model is a
classic two-by-two matrix that you see
in consultancy handbooks and in those
models the framework precedes the data
as a result of which is very fast
because we can just drop the dot the
data into the appropriate box and decide
accordingly the danger is that actually
we won't see subtle differences until
they're too late so we'll be caught out
it's a categorization is good for
exploitation it's pretty poor for
exploration or during periods of change
a sense making framework on the other
hand the data precedes the framework the
patterns or the framework itself emerges
from the data in a social process now
for the purpose of this brief
explanation I'm going to treat it as a
set of categories but that's the
important distinction categorization
models framework precedes data sense
making models data proceeds framework
and of course one can become the other
and we'll need resetting from time to
time
we take the three basic systems here
ordered systems complex systems chaotic
systems we create a new category called
disorder and we divide order into two
simple and complicated in the simple
domain this is an ordered system that
means the relationship between cause and
effect exists is predictable it can be
determined in advance in simple order
that relationship is self-evident to any
reasonable person as a result of which
the decision model is sense categorize
respond we see what's coming in we make
it fit previously to him in categories
we decide what to do the model here is
that we apply best practice a phrase
which is legitimate in this domain but
illegitimate in other domains in the
complicated domain there is a
relationship between cause and effect
there is a right answer but it's not
self-evident so I either have to deploy
an analytical method
hence sense analyze respond all calling
experts who built expertise within that
domain who can make the right decision
accordingly I don't apply best practice
I apply good practice distinction
between good and best practice is
actually quite important in a
complicated domain there are several
different ways of doing things all of
which legitimate if you have the right
expertise and trying to force people to
adopt one of them is actually quite
dangerous you will basically piss people
off to be honest to the point where they
won't apply best practice where it
should be applied it so simple and
complicated we're familiar with sense
categorize respond sense analyze respond
best practice or good practice
complexity on the other hand is a system
without causality it's a system of light
constraints on agents agents modify the
system so our decision model here is
probe sense respond we conduct safe
failed experiments we don't do failsafe
design if an experiment
seeds we amplified if the experiment
starts to fail we dampen it in fact we
shouldn't even do an experiment and as
we've identified our amplification and
dampening strategies in advance and of
course what happens here is we get
emergent order by something which comes
out of it is emergent practice it's a
new way of doing things it's novel it
may be some combination but it's
different and it's unique in a chaotic
environment if we enter it deliberately
it's for innovation but if we enter it
accidentally then we need to stabilize
the position quickly so the decision
model is act sense respond we move very
quickly to stabilize a situation any
practice will be completely novel in
terms of the way things work now you'll
notice that that gives us a very easy
way of deciding how to work but it gives
us a divergent we sometimes call this
requisite applicability
it basically says dependent on which
space you're in you should think
differently you should analyze
differently rather than a
one-size-fits-all which has been a
tradition of management theory now the
central space disorder and this is key
is the space of not knowing which of the
domains you're in and that's where we
are most of the time and the trouble
then is we will interpret the situation
according to our personal preference for
action our danger is if you spend two or
three years of your life in a purely
bureaucratic process based role then you
tend to see all problems as a failure of
process if you're a deep expert then any
problem is a failure to give you enough
time or resource to do analysis natural
complexity workers battlefield
commanders politicians their reaction to
a crisis is to get lots of different
people together from lots of different
backgrounds in the desperate hope that
somebody will come up with the right
solution that's actually quite a good
strategy and of course the fascist lever
crisis because then they can be given
absolute command of everybody who has to
do what they're told
so what you get in a normal decision
environment is that people are in a
disordered space assessing the situation
according to their preference for action
one of the main functions of the
Canarian framework is to allow people to
say hang on a minute it's complex
therefore we probe or hang our mate
that's complicated which experts should
we bring to their
another key aspect of the Calabrian
framework which is frequently missed off
by people who try and over simplified is
the boundary between simple and chaotic
is different from the other boundaries
it's actually represented in the Harvard
Business Review article as a cliff or in
other articles as a symbolic type of
wave at the bottom yeah the principle
here is if you start to believe that
things are simple you start to believe
that they're ordered you start to
believe in your own myths
you start to believe that past success
means you're invulnerable to future
failure you effectively move to the
complacent zone which is the boundary
between simple and chaotic and you fall
over the edge in a crisis and all the
other boundaries allow for transitions
for this you fall over the edge and
recovery is very very expensive
it therefore follows that you should
manage in the complicated and complex
basis and only move a very small amount
of material down into the simple because
that's actually highly vulnerable to
rapid or accelerated change so the
conniving framework is a decision
framework it's an analytical framework
it's being used for decision theory it's
been used for knowledge management is
being used variety design for project
management is it recognizes the causal
differences that exists between
different types of systems and gives
people a very quick and easy way to flip
between them so they can use the
appropriate method for the appropriate
domain